yes today I am we are recording in the
room this is the room then many women
chose not to come up - mm-hmm lucky you
lucky you hey what is going on with you
people in here fucking-a she has ankles
do something about that so as mentioned
before in the previous video I asked if
you guys wanted to know how I got to
lose the 30 pounds now it's really hard
to put all the knowledge I've gained
from experimenting with my body over and
over again wow that sounds [ __ ] dirty
basically what I'm saying is not gonna
happen on the win video so I'm just
gonna compartmentalize compartment I'm
going to split up a lot of the different
advice that I have to lose weight into
you know just various videos because
it's not gonna come to me all at once
and it's impossible just to put it in
one video so let's just start with this
video by talking about what got me to
lose the weight in the first place now I
have struggled with my weight my whole
life and what I mean by that is you're
not so much it's like I would wake up
and be like you know you're fed you know
that's not me that was something that I
dealt with early on like probably in
junior high and then when I got into
high school I just you know I kind of
like you know learn to love and
appreciate myself yeah I owned up to
what sin I was like yo you fat boy but
you cute [ __ ] but for me this struggle
was in like feeling healthy and good you
know what I mean because you know when
you're a teen right or even when you're
like 21 years old if you're fat or
you're overweight you still seem to have
like an abundance of energy and the only
reason why is because you [ __ ] young
as [ __ ] like in your lifespan when
there's a one still in front of your
[ __ ] number
you basically just came out of a [ __ ]
slowly after I you know I was in my 20s
I was like yo man I'm definitely
starting to feel the the fatness you
know I'm saying and ever since that
point I have been constantly yo-yoing on
my way just back and forth back and
forth I would lose 10 pounds out with
those 15 pounds and then I would gain
back 30 then another two it's been a
struggle and that's why I I started this
thing called funny fat fit a while ago
and it wasn't so much for me a lot of it
honestly was for you I mean losing
weight didn't make me love myself any
more than I already did I love myself
like I never had a problem with loving
myself
never really been depressed it's just I
really started to feel the effects of
being overweight and it [ __ ] suck
I would like open up a bag of chips and
people would ask hey bro you just run a
marathon while you sweating so hard I
opened up a bag of Cheetos [ __ ] [ __ ]
you huh and it came to a point where I
had to be honest with myself number one
I'm not getting any younger
number two you know a lot of people
around me were starting to worry about
me just because my health was
deteriorating so bad my skin was [ __ ]
terrible I wasn't getting any [ __ ]
sleep none of my clothes would fit I was
breathing super heavy my sleep apnea
came back I mean the delicious goes on
and on and on and every day I was waking
up I was trying to find a reason to work
out to improve my life to become
healthier and I couldn't [ __ ] find it
[ __ ] it was stressful as [ __ ] you have
any idea how many times I watched rocky
to motivate my ass oh I watched that
movie so [ __ ] much it started talking
like the dude is [ __ ] yo a do with those
because you had brain dead
but one day something hit me really hard
right in the [ __ ] heart and it was
from a podcast that I heard on Joe
Rogan's podcast where he interviewed a
guy named David Goggins you know I I had
all the right motivating factors my
friends my family you know my girlfriend
who was concerned about me and it just
it just didn't click with me I didn't
understand every time somebody told me I
should get my health right I just want
to tell me shut the [ __ ] up get away
from me I'm not going to really go into
too much about who David Goggins is and
what his story is all about because
y'all sure listened that for yourself
it's not really I can't really do it
justice he became a Navy SEAL finished
hell week multiple times within one year
used to be really really [ __ ] fat very
disadvantaged his whole life stories
[ __ ] up but he somehow not only
succeeded in what he wanted to he
excelled even like his own expectations
of himself and the cool thing that I got
from that was just not so much setting
goals to disapprove what other people
say or think about you but is to fight
your own inner demons I think like we
get so caught up in trying to prove
something to somebody else we kind of
forget that the first person that you
might have to prove wrong is that person
inside of you that constantly doubts you
every day and I always told people this
and I never really took it to heart
myself was if you are the first person
to tell yourself that you can't do
something then you're already [ __ ] up
see because the rest of the world is
designed to kind of put you down I think
humans have this habit of when they see
somebody succeed there's a lot of people
out there they just want to push you
down and if already the world is
designed to do that then why are you the
first person to tell yourself that you
can't do something and I was doing that
every [ __ ] day and I was doing it
through [ __ ] excuses and what I got
from that podcast that I really enjoyed
was that David Goggin wasn't telling you
to be him he was saying that you need to
set goals for yourself and fight those
inner demons and kind of just do what
you can do don't base your goals on what
I do as a person but just do that for
yourself and on top of all this he also
helped me understand that there is
supposed to be comfort in discomfort
meaning that you cannot achieve
something in this world without being a
little bit uncomfortable the things that
you want are always on the other side of
discomfort the crazy thing is his advice
you know I wouldn't even call it advice
his life story was basically teaching me
a lesson not only in weight loss alone
it was just what I was doing with my
life after I finished the film but the
first thing that I did when I listen to
that podcast was I took personal
responsibility and I said you know what
if you want to get up and you want to
change this thing about yourself and you
want to become healthier nobody else is
gonna do it for you you don't have to
run a thousand [ __ ] mile smash a
million [ __ ] waist but David you got
to do something and the one thing that I
knew that I could do on a regular basis
let's just walk and I know that's so
crazy right it's like David so are you
telling me that you lost a majority of
your weight by just walking kind of yes
yes there is the diet part which is a
huge part of it but I'm gonna have to
get into that in another video but the
reason why I'm saying all I had to do
was walk because when I started to walk
and I'm talking about every day three
miles every day it did something for me
not only did it help me burn calories
and to help me become active what it did
for me the most is that it taught me
a habit rain sunshine when it doesn't
[ __ ] matter no matter what you can
always just walk whether it's a mile two
miles or three miles you don't have to
do three miles like I did but you just
have to walk what it does once again it
teaches you habit and also teaches you
that you can complete something on a
daily [ __ ] basis now I've heard a lot
of people out there say some stupid [ __ ]
because I know a lot of dudes out there
are all about like grinding weight and
put in the [ __ ] work in your stupid
[ __ ] and I'm not hating on people who
like to lift weights I [ __ ] lift
weights too but I just don't like that
pressure that people give cuz some
people have the dumbest [ __ ] logic
when it comes to the type of activity
that fat people need to do when they
just start to work out yo go to the
window push their [ __ ] weight [ __ ]
how about you hold a steak in your mouth
in a [ __ ] lion's cage you [ __ ]
[ __ ] give you any advice it's
just to do a low-impact activity that
you can complete to show yourself then
you can actually do something on a daily
basis and once again build a habit
whether in the first month or not you're
gonna lose weight from this or whatever
don't even [ __ ] with the scale I'm just
telling you for me that it might work
for you is that I'm trying to fix this
I'm trying to get myself to complete
something without always expecting this
great thing at the end in return just to
be able to complete something fill
something in your heart and your mind
that you're going to need to continue
this healthy lifestyle for the rest of
your [ __ ] life and I'm telling you
people might say like oh you should do
more will [ __ ] them they don't
understand what the purpose of it and I
just told you what the purpose is and
you could tell them right in their
[ __ ] faces like walking your sport
[ __ ] walking is for [ __ ] [ __ ]
walking is a basic necessity what the
[ __ ] are you talking about listen I
[ __ ] love power lifters I have a lot
of power lovely friends it's [ __ ]
amazing what they do but you better stop
talking [ __ ] about my [ __ ] Walker
Tommy telling people that walking is
useless it's like saying that breathing
is you you what the [ __ ] [ __ ] you
breathe it today homie it's a [ __ ] ass
[ __ ] really [ __ ] breathing is for
[ __ ] oh and hold your breath forever
and die [ __ ] so for my bigger
people out there that are watching all
these like Instagram videos and these
other Fitness people and you've never
worked out a day in your [ __ ] life
and you're
smash weights and run for miles a day
slow your [ __ ] butter roll that was a
fat jump it was said to me before and I
found it hilarious but I don't want to
give them a satisfaction sauce I don't
you say that to me but on the inside
outside that's [ __ ] funny don't ask
your body to do crazy [ __ ] [ __ ] out
of nowhere you know what I'm saying like
it took an eternity for you to get out
of shape like it took you a while to get
to this point so it's gonna take you a
while to get healthy it's common sense
it's logic a lot of [ __ ] that you see
out there that says loose 50 pounds it
[ __ ] 20 days [ __ ] those people just
do you don't worry about the scale and
take my advice and prove to yourself
that you can commit to something for at
least one month and if you're going to
do this let me know in the comments
below and if you think of some [ __ ] ass
[ __ ] then you could talk to me a person
saw me trying to get these hands
[ __ ] I'm just kidding I can't I
can't fight say my life are those
parrots shut the [ __ ]
Pasadena has parrots
[Music]
you
[Music]